gobiernos latinoamericanos e
instituciones multilaterales
reaccionaron ante la crisis política de
Perú desatada tras la destitución de
Pedro Castillo por querer disolver el
congreso e instaurar Un gobierno de
emergencia la Organización de Estados
Americanos oea rechazó las medidas
adoptadas por el ahora expresidente la
secretaría general de la oea se declara
del lado de la Democracia al Estado de
derecho y la promoción y protección de
derechos humanos y las libertades
lo ocurrido hoy en Perú al disolver
Pedro Castillo El Congreso de la
República sin base constitucional legal
ni normativa constituye una alteración
del orden constitucional en el país en
un día difícil para la democracia en el
hemisferio debemos estar presentes como
organización reacciones que llegaron
desde Estados Unidos hasta Argentina
gobiernos latinoamericanos lamentaron la
situación y abogaron por el diálogo el
gobierno de chile lamenta profundamente
la situación política que está viviendo
la República del Perú y confía en que
esta crisis que afecta a un país hermano
se pueda resolver a través de mecanismos
democráticos y El Respeto del Estado de
derecho Colombia a través de su
cancillería condenó todo atentado contra
la democracia venga de donde venga el
gobierno de Luis Arce en Bolivia hizo un
llamado a todos los involucrados a
garantizar los principios democráticos
la administración del estadounidense Joe
biden advirtió sobre el peligro que
corre la democracia peruana
rechazamos categóricamente cualquier
acto de eludir o contradecir la
Constitución de Perú rechazamos
categóricamente cualquier acto que
socave la democracia dentro de Perú
en contra del rechazo internacional el
presidente mexicano Andrés Manuel López
Obrador acusó a las élites económicas y
políticas de Perú de forzar a Castillo a
tomar decisiones que derivaron en su
destitución y su cancillería se dijo
dispuesta a ofrecerle asilo